It is time for Drew's News,
your king-size good news burrito packed with extra
good news beans, and with me at the desk,
my trustee co-pilot, Ross Matthews.
Hi, everybody, hi.
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
And we have a dynamic duo with us today.
He is an SNL alum, actor, podcast host, and comedian
with standup shows coming this spring at Arlington improv,
it's Finesse Mitchell!
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
Hello, hello everyone.
And she is an Emmy nominated actress, comedian, mother,
entrepreneur, and NAACP award nominee, Kym Whitley!
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
Congratulations, Kym.
Just announced.
Yes, just announced, me and Sherri Shepherd
just got nominated, our podcast, Two Funny Mamas,
for NAACP Image Awards so please, go vote, go vote, go vote.
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
Who go the purple note and the yellow?
I was like, "Somebody should've told me about the little
purple note.
We were DM'ing each other, you know what I'm saying?
No, we were not, he walked out like, "No, Ross.
This is how you wear a purple suit"
And I'm like, "I'm taking notes"
Big shout out to Sebastian Cruz for hooking me up.
He's a buddy out of South Florida.
I love that suit.
Sebastian, you are so awesome.
See, you look hot, I look like Barney, you know?
Like a big (mimics Barney the dinosaur)
Don't you say that about my friend, you're hot.
Yes, you are!
I've been knowing you a long time.
I was just about to say that too, Kym.
I've been knowing him a while, and he finally grew up,
like, you look like a grown man, finally.
You think so?
I finally caught your eye, huh, Kym?
Yes, yes!
This is the romance
storyline we did not see coming.
(Finesse and Ross laughing)
Two Funny Mamas, two hot men in purple.
Yes!
Hey, hey.
All right, should we hit the headlines, guys?
Yes.
I'm ready.
All right, first up,
we have got some fresh Kim, Kanye, Pete Davidson news.
They love this.
The 2022 thing you didn't know you needed,
the blog SheKnows reports that Kanye's got a song out.
It's brand new, with some fighting words for Pete Davidson,
but allegedly, Pete finds it hilarious.
The lyrics are, "God saved me from that crash
so I can beat Pete Davidson's" you know what.
What rhymes with "crash"?
Except he didn't say,
"you know what".
Exactly, Finesse.
Allegedly, Pete never wants to feud with Kanye
because that's the dad of Kim's kids.
Plus, he expected to be referenced in one of his songs
sooner or later.
Discuss.
Oh my God.
Right?
Are you into this?
I absolutely love it.
We knew Kanye was gonna do this.
I mean, did we expect less?
No!
No, and I think Pete
absolutely loves it, he's happy about it.
The thing is, I think he's a little afraid.
Just a little bit.
Pete?
Yes, Pete's a little afraid.
Really?
Yes.
But he's not afraid of Kanye.
He's afraid of Kanye's fans.
I'm just saying.
Oh God, that turned dark.
Turned dark, right?
My God, one a minute I'm like, "Oh, this is so fun"
And the next minute I'm like, "Run, this is terrifying!"
I do get so excited though, when there's just a little,
teeny celebrity beef.
It's my second favorite kind of beef after hamburger.
It's like, when celebrities start going at each other,
and I have to say, at one time, I've told you I had gone
to the Kardashian Christmas party before.
Okay, it's one of my best things I've ever done
in my entire life, and I bring it up every chance I can.
And I was behind Kanye West in the buffet line.
And I remember thinking to myself, "Ross, if you cut
in front of him, he could write a rap song about you"
That's like the dream to happen.
So you know Pete Davidson, fan of rap, fan of pop culture,
a little bit of him is like,
"This is so cool that I'm in a Kanye West song"
Wouldn't you think it's cool, you guys?
Yes.
Absolutely.
Totally.
I would love for Kanye West to write a song,
or just put me in a lyric or whatever.
As long as it's, especially if he says he's gonna beat my,
my booty, beat my butt, you know what I mean?
Yeah, that's not nice.
I mean, that's not nice, but I'll take,
'cause now I'm beefing with Kanye,
and even though I can't rap and I'm thinking,
Pete's thinking the same thing, like, we're standup comics.
What can you say in response?
You're not gonna go in a studio.
I think he handled it the right way,
because the alternative is to be like,
"Kanye, I'ma meet you in the studio or I'ma meet you
on the street"
And I think Pete would lose both battles.
(upbeat music)